exactly one year ago Donald Trump defied
the odds to win the most surprising
presidential victory perhaps of all time
he busted through the so-called blue
wall winning 30 states compared to
Hillary's paltry 20 in his victory
speech he promised this it's going to be
a beautiful thing every single American
will have the opportunity to realize his
or her fullest potential they're
forgotten men and women of our country
will be forgotten no longer
that's like 2:30 in the morning as I
recall what a night it was amazing
and a year ago let's not forget the
experts were all proven wrong for months
and months the pollsters the consultants
and of course the media told us that
Trump had no chance and even as the
returns were coming in in the news
anchors were sitting there slack-jawed
or some of them weeping they still clung
to their narrative but as we know the
people rose up they were sick of the
Washington machine taking their power
away from them so what do they do they
took it back and ever since that same
political media and entertainment
complex have been trying to regain their
power
last night President Trump and his party
suffered a series of losses the
Democrats netted wins and the governor's
races in Virginia and in New Jersey and
even though citizens up in Maine the
maniacs overwhelmingly voted in favor of
an Obamacare program that expands
Medicaid the reaction on the left was
understandably euphoric and many began
to declare that this meant the end of
Trump and the end of his conservative
populist movement it's hard to overstate
the degree of toxicity that Trump
represents right now in the base of what
we saw yesterday
election was to some degree a referendum
on Trump and obviously he did
exceptionally badly it's a good night
for Democrats and I think a rejection to
a degree of Trump and perhaps even more
than Trump Trump ISM what we showed was
this party is much
boring now under the weight of this
trump presidency wishful thinking boys
these are the same experts who have been
writing Trump's political obituary since
he and Melania came down the escalator
in the Trump Tower in June 2015 these
are the same Talking Heads who told us
he'd never win the GOP primary and by
the way if he did he'd get creamed by
Hillary in the general and of course if
he did that he would do lasting damage
to the GOP a year ago tonight they were
all over TV with her hangdog expressions
embarrassed and exposed and now they
feel like they've been vindicated
because of an off-year election where
the party and power usually loses to put
it in context both Virginia and New
Jersey let's face it a pretty much blue
states it was all but assured that the
Democrats were gonna win there and even
the president let's not forget he lost
in those states let's not forget that
before yesterday the Democrats had lost
every major special congressional
election this year media didn't mention
much of that last night Republicans held
onto seats this year in Georgia South
Carolina Kansas and Montana and those
Democratic losses came despite non-stop
cheerleading from the mainstream media
as well as plenty of campaign cash still
let's be honest here the Republicans and
the president they do have some lessons
to take away from last night I think
they've gone about as far as they can go
with the politics of anger they now need
a happy electorate in 2018 one that sees
its future brighter and frankly one that
sees the country a little bit calmer
remember what president-elect Trump told
the nation a year ago in that victory
speech I say it is time for us to come
together as one United people
I pledge to every citizen of our land
that I will be President for all
Americans I love that he has a lot of
good news that needs to be shared with
Americans even those who did not support
him the economy is soaring the stock
markets at record levels consumer
confidence is up unemployment is at a
17-year low and I'm just getting started
with that list president Trump's efforts
think about it too renegotiating NAFTA
and other trade deals those are bound to
help American workers and in case you
didn't notice
he's a law-and-order president deporting
violent illegal aliens and cracking down
on gangs like ms-13 that is good stuff
for everybody here the president and the
GOP leadership however they must work
together they got to start racking up
legislative victories that show voters
even those who usually don't vote for
Republicans that conservative populist
policies are improving their lives in
making the country happier remember the
pursuit of happiness happy voters vote
for the party and power angry voters
vote the party and power out that's what
happened a year ago tonight the
Republicans do not want to see the
tables reversed on them in 2018 and
that's the angle